[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to another episode of
whats up r hi Martin good day Walter
good day how you doing okay I'm fine do
you like the backdrop that Henry
produced for us beautiful well I I would
like to move that that minute hand a
little closer to the midnight I'm I'm
with you there one second or how many
seconds yeah um 11
5959 59 59 I see the color has changed
from our previous one little bit more
where we saw a little bit of red now
it's dark blue yeah and
it's it's getting darker it's getting
darker yes all right so we're not
finished with the Jesuits and
their uh shenan Shenanigans is a nice
word thank you
Martin so how did they start introducing
this spirituality into
mainstream so how did they put it into
practice Yeah so can just briefly just
recap what we've seen in the previous um
lecture we've to shown how the
spirituality of nasas laola how they
used it to infiltrate the Protestant
churches yes
I think we must pray Martin oh of course
we may not start this without prayer no
this is a very important thing to do our
heavenly father we are so thankful that
we have the Bible that you produced into
our hands that we can discern what is
going on so we ask now in this
discussion that you also Enlighten our
minds and help that we can discern in
Jesus name amen
amen now robt Chula was another 33°
Freemason and he built this edifice
Crystal Palace
MH and he asked for the blessing of the
Pope upon this
structure which is very enlightening of
course and he loved to expound on the
power of positive thinking which he got
from his mentor Norman Vincent Peele
another 33 de G Freemason and we know
that when they reach the 33rd degree
that they know that Lucifer is their
true God yeah he also loved his
robes and always loved to perform and
appear in his robes and he once got into
a major argument with a flight attendant
because I don't know what they did they
maybe you know ruffled a little corner
of the robe when they put it into
wherever they hang it up and it was all
over the news so robes and appearance
and paper recognition was very important
to all of these individuals but their
teachings are of course uh Jesuit
inspired so how do we get this
spirituality story settled here now Paul
yongo who heads the world's largest
church in South Korea which is of course
a charismatic church
wrote a book called the fourth
dimension and in the forward to the book
Robert Schuler said the following in
regard to
visualization I discovered the reality
of that Dynamic Dimension fourth
dimension in prayer that comes through
visualizing don't try to understand it
just start to enjoy it it's true it
works I tried
it so do we have ignatian spirituality
there 100 % and he of course was the
mentor of Rick Warren you see who became
the father of
protestantism I really don't need that
father no and it's so important we
actually should have um showed that clip
again the first uh clip that we showed
in the previous one what is how
important is
protestantism it is from God it's from
God and this is from below and uh of
course Rick Warren wrote his famous book
that was circulated into every single
denomination including many in our own
denomination used that to my great
horror but nevertheless that is the way
the human psych works you know that book
The Purpose Driven Life and it's all
about this social Doctrine that's it
it's all about these things we'll see in
a moment so we continue with the same
thing the destruction and the
dismantling of
protestantism by the Jesuits the most
diabolical organization that has ever
disgraced this Earth and that's not you
turning saying that that comes that's um
inspired that's very inspired yes so
visualization is hypnosis Martin and
here are the quotes psychologist Michael
yapo explains many times therapists
aren't even aware that they are doing
hypnosis they're doing what they call
guided imagery which is visualization or
guided meditation which are all very
mainstream hypnotic techniques and these
charismatic preachers like Benny hen and
all of them they use them and these
people fall over and they call that
slain in the spirit no it's slain in
demonic activity by hypnosis yeah so the
Mystic experience here is a very
interesting article it's about K
Yung and it states how his experience
came about swith psychologist and major
contributor to psychotherapy Carl Jung
cultivated the ability to have visions
from Deep imagination that's ignatian
spirituality some would label these
Explorations as mystical experience
While others would say they are more
akin to the sort of creative thinking
artists
do in addition to these experiences Yung
had several spontaneous Visions when he
was recovering from a heart attack when
he was
69 all of his Visions are described in
detail in his book memories dreams and
Reflections so this was also what
ignasius Lola experienced and remember
we quoted from the historic sources and
these cheric uh apparitions appeared to
him and he was Guided by the spirit
world and the Word was negated
yeah so Yung uses a visual technique
that he found helps him go deeper into
active
imagination and this technique is a
realistic visualization of descending to
a great distance isn't it interesting
that you always go down you don't go up
in this experience he figures that he
has descended about a th000 ft Allison
Wonderland also goes down and gets her
inspiration from beneath not from
above there discovers a cosmic abis
that's where the devil lives
Martin next he sees something like a
Moon crater and then he has the feeling
that he is in the Land of the Dead huh
so the old man turns out he sees a
biblical figure right that he sees a old
man and he asks him who he is and the
old man turns out to be
Elijah and the girl that is with him is
salomi and he's thinking still what a
strange couple he Muses now remember
salomi is the one who danced before
Herod and asked for the head of John the
Baptist exactly so so the Elijah message
and salomi are like yingyang they just
don't fit together but here they are
together yeah yeah but Elijah tells Yung
that he and salomi belong together for
all eternity that's yingyang
philosophy along with the two is a third
a large black snake that sounds very
realistic Yung sticks close to Elijah
and keeps his distance from
salomi so he's attracted to White
spiritism rather than black
spiritism what this is all demonic stuff
yeah
now St Louis
University practicing osian passion now
this is fascinating and they asked the
question car Yung and the spiritual
exercises of Ignatius Lola isn't that
interesting wonderful so you this is St
Louis University and the presenter is
Anthony Mo he's a PhD a special
assistant to the president of Georgetown
University do we have our Jesuits all
over the place again everywhere you
won't find any of this without them
there they're always in these dark
underground corridors performing their
vile activities whatever they may
be what do a 20th century Swift
psychoanalyst and a 16th century Spanish
Mystic have to say to each other the
workshop is based on the premise that
Carl Jung offers a uniquely compatible
psychological framework for
understanding the dynamic of the
spiritual exercises of Ignatius LOL I
don't think we have to read more I mean
that already that shows
you we The
Same Spirit is leading yes and where
does it lead to let's just read the last
sentence it leads to your authentic self
there you go again connecting the
unconscious psychic energy and hearing
the call of the king and who's the king
it's the Pope
yeah not Jesus Christ so you must know
how they phrase stuff like you mentioned
ear in the previous one with the Jesuit
General stating that you can have the
discernment and that discernment will
come again like that mentioned here from
South can you
imagine Elijah and salomi connected in
this Union
forever good and evil living side by
side connected to each other by an
umbilical cord can you imagine something
like that so let's take it to the rest
of the media the Opera Winfrey website
promotes a course and miracles MH now a
course and miracles as you know was
written by Helen
shookman and she was a psychologist so
we have the psychology of Yung
infiltrating Into the Mystic world and
then you become an alter Christos you
become Christ and anything he can do you
can do better anything he can do you can
do better than he it's so pathetic it's
unbelievable so according to Marian A
Course in Miracles is a self-study
program of spiritual
Psychotherapy contained in three books
it's not a religion but rather a
psychological mind training based on
universal spiritual themes you become
Christ you are God this is the teaching
of the serpent you see especially in the
Modern Age the last 20 years this
psychological training all this these
type of books I mean still today it's so
prevalent everybody because it's not
spir it's not religion based but it
teaches you something about how you
yourself must be better you Opera
Winfrey always presents this Christian
Fai and she will invite speakers from a
a wide
range including those that actually know
the truth yeah and just dump it all in
there into an ecumenical pot and make a
stew so let's see what she has to say
the power of
meditation Oprah and life coach there
you have a coach
again Cheryl Richardson talk about the
importance of meditation and explain how
you can get started centering up for
your
self everything is out of here where
there is nothing but wickedness
according to the scripture so don't
worry if nothing miraculous happens in
the next 5 minutes as long as you spend
five minutes of quiet time with yourself
just turning your vision
inward which is what closing your eyes
allows you to do you've succeeded you've
accomplished something very important as
a matter of fact probably one of the
most important things in your life so
I'm going to just do a 5 minute
meditation guided visualization IGN in
spirituality we just saw it from the
University that it's one and the same
thing you might want to put things down
on the floor around you get comfortable
sit in a way that feels comfortable so
Oprah says to her so just start there
and you will be surprised by the
discipline that comes from doing it on a
regular basis how your life begins to
unfold for you differently I call it
centering upon myself for myself I'd
rather Center on Christ oh for
sure so Martin we've shown before that
these kinds of
exercises are being practiced by those
in high political places today mhm so
let's have a look at this again just for
the sake of completeness you you've got
four months you're facing what do you
plan to do with that time
like what are you going to read what are
you going to spend your time doing in
well I I you know I I have a pretty
strict regimen as is so I'll continue on
I I do a lot of uh spiritual exercises
following uh St Ignatius Loyola you know
different uh spiritual exercise that
come out of the Catholic church although
I'm a uh I'm a uh I I would actually say
if you look at our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ I would call myself a
pre-christian I I wouldn't want to
insult His Name by saying I'm a
Christian given the the the very tough
in high high standard so Martin is this
is this something that is deceased in
the time that we are living in or is it
alive and well and living in Washington
exactly that's ex excellently put
because it's exactly people that would
say ah no but it's arbitrary no I'm
sorry uh all right okay now what about
sport that's also something that puts
you into a Mindless State and this is a
a touchy subject yes because you jump up
and down if somebody scores a goal or
whatever and you go into deep depression
if someone else scores a goal you know
goal is a goal why aren't you happy when
when the more hits the net that's
supposed to be it if if you really think
of it if it was Christian based if you
had a sport that's Christian based that
would be exactly the thing everybody
will work together to do the same thing
and everybody will cheer each other I
think if we plowed up all the fields and
planted potatoes it would be an
excellent thing at least people would
have food to eat sounds familiar I've
heard that before the Jesuits and Sport
they're the ones in the government
they're the ones behind the professional
sports the owner of the Pittsburgh
Steelers is a knight of Malta the owner
of the Detroit Lions is a knight of
Malta all the top owners of these clubs
for the most part on nights of Malta
getting the people whooped up on this
hoopla over games and Sport while
they're busy creating a tyranny this
comes from the black pope and uh it's
a just another
confirmation that sport is really
another form of worship oh for sure I
mean there's a clip where
Madonna was talking about she had to do
the ceremony she called it yes the main
um sermon in the holy of holies yes and
that was all done at the Super Bowl
correct so this is all part of Jesuit
spirituality take the mind of the
scriptures focus it on Roman games yeah
he'll do it in the church he'll do it in
the arena he'll do it in the movie
theater and he'll do it in the white
house and in the halls of
government so visualization in sport we
don't have to go into great detail but
this is how it actually happens it's
more of a mind training than anything
else all right so when I finished school
when I was about 30 years old I had this
urge to do because I loved Athletics so
I went and I trained and we went to do
Master's Athletics and um our coach
actually a interesting name m yeah yeah
your coach coach yes we actually did
visualizations psychology MH you were
lying down they were playing a music
some one of the best songs that they'll
always use depending on which um
activity you'll do is uh Chariots of
Fire uhuh so when you listen to this
music you visualize your whole uh race
and how you end up winning that's how
you get trained in this type of okay so
this exactly what they do
so your confidence your strength of
cration they are improved do you train
great but perform badly in
competitions do you sometimes feel
physically sick when you're about to
compete or just looking to improve and
move upon in with things so they use
mentally imagining yourself performing
at your peak level exactly what you just
said and this is a great part of uh the
preparation for athletes particularly
Olympic athletes so effective
visualization is the answer to
overcoming most triathletes problems so
the main reason why the daily
visualization according is so effective
is because automatic relaxation the
hypnotic recording places you into an
easy and automatic state of relaxation
so you listen to this music
mhm and it gets more powerful each day
the recording has been designed to
become stronger and more effective by
the day it can even work while you're
asleep even if you go to sleep listening
to the recording you still receive the
sublimal benefits so your subconscious
is most open to suggestion when you are
asleep or relaxed so your best training
takes place when you're sleeping yeah
because it's a mind thing yes all right
so let's look at some of the people
involved here is a web page swim Psych
ology and crave townend he is the
director and he has a diploma in
clinical hypnosis so it's hypnosis
that's it and M hypnosis when something
takes over your mind and it's not
God then it's a demon
yeah so these techniques they use them
on swimmers they use them on athletes
they train all of these people here's
another trainer
and he uses visualization that has
helped millions and he's uh has an
article the clinical psychologist who
has worked with Olympic athletes and
Team Canada etc etc and they use these
very techniques so they've put the
philosophy and the psychology all the
place you'll think it it it happens in
sports I mean you think it's a good
thing because you are
um imagining yourself in a good
situation winning a race and this is
just training your mind so this sounds
innocent yes so now take the same
technique and bring it into a spiritual
realm it is spiritual you can already
but they don't know it yeah now you
bring it into a spiritual realm and it
doesn't matter whether it's Hindu
whether it's Buddhist or whether it's
Catholic or whether it's charismatic
it's the same
principle so let's have a look at the
new age ascended masters Research Center
and they use visualization because these
are gems from the ascended masters let's
call them ascended demons No actually
they're descended demons they never
ascended they always come out of the
bottomless pit so true visualization is
God's attribute and power of sight
acting on the mind of man well it's
another God yeah when one consciously
pictures in the mind a desire he wishes
fulfilled he's using one of the most
powerful means of bringing it into the
visible tangible experience they do that
in the economy that's it they tell you
to visualize that you are getting a lot
of money successful yeah and then you
will get it it's a very very dangerous
thing to do there was a book that came
out in the middle
2000s it was called the secret and that
was this positive thinking and the more
you think of it positive the more you
you will attract money money and all
success towards you it was huge I think
it was the whole world I think don't I
think they even made courses on this
it's in the same New Age philosophy is
this it's it's uh how shall I put this
Martin it's very
comforting because let's say you have a
problem and you start visualizing that
this problem is going to be resolved in
this and this and this
way then you are relying on these things
to sustain you and you are waiting for
the solution to come your way ex the
victory or the money or the this or the
great
opportunity it is a it let's call it a
crutch that you are leaning on
in order to take you through the bumpy
periods uh my God will take care of all
your needs so do we need to do this no
and if we have done it and I think
everybody has everybody has these
moments of
visualizing uh success where you've had
nothing but Quagmire of
failures and it's a nice way of escape
and another way to escape like that is
to grab a novel yeah or to grab a movie
switch off the mind and just let the
flickering light by the way that's
hypnosis exactly if you look at the old
definition of hypnosis it was a darkened
room with a flickering
screen that's a movie that's exactly
puts you into an altered state of
consciousness and then these mind these
ideas come in often if you ask the
people outside what did you see they
can't even remember exactly they don't
know what's going on so this is very
very dangerous so we should
actually actively work against it what
is that is it a quote God the of your
mind the Avenues of your mind yes all
right so true visualization is a god
attribute really is it occultism has
always involved three techniques for
changing and creating reality thinking
speaking and
visualization this is Dave Hunt ult
Invasion so this is what's happening in
the world and it's spearheaded by Jesuit
thinking and it's crazy because this is
the same exercises being used in sport
now you see the new age and it's also
being used in Christian denominations
yeah all right so Robert Schuler teaches
that the church's problem is that it had
a god centered theology for centuries
when it needs a man centered one this is
self-esteem the new Reformation that's
his own
words so the question is where' he get
this
from well at the conclusion of Vatican 2
Pope Paul I 6 told the Bishops that
their church had decided to opt for man
to serve man to help him build his home
on this
Earth Martin what does the Bible tell
you you should
be my kingdom is not of this world not
of this world man with his ideas and his
aims man with his hopes and fears man in
his difficulties and suffering that was
the centerpiece of the church's interest
said the pontiff to the Bishops so this
is the Vatican 2
issue and it take us away the whole
desire to be with Jesus and a better
Kingdom
it's a social justice
standing so he started saying schula you
don't know what power you have within
you you make the world anything you
choose yes you can make your world into
whatever you want it to be once again
this these are the influences that
influence Donald Trump in his thinking
correct and you can see this and they
come via the 33°
Freemasons as we have said Norman
Vincent
schula said it's time for Protestants to
go to the shepherd talking about the
pope and say what do we have to do to
come home in other words what do we do
to end protestantism isn't this the aim
of the Jesuits that's 100% what it
is when schula was planning for the
building of his Crystal Cathedral he
made a special trip to Rome to ask the
Pub's blessing on the building plans so
there's the quote for what I said
previously
so Martin let's just get this under
under our knee here true meditation is
always word-based that's it and there's
a false
meditation it's Gaga based yeah or
sitting and repeating a word for an hour
or listening to Mantra music and G and
becoming brain
dead Psalms 119 and verse 148 mine eyes
preent in the night Watchers that I may
Med meditate in thy
word you do that by reading and asking
what does this mean Lord that's
meditating
not give me an experience here let me
smell it let me taste it let me touch it
let me hear what you are saying I don't
want to read it just tell me in my ear
now you're touching where it's getting
serious yeah with the
senses when I remember thee upon my B
bed and Med meditate on thee in the
night watches I will meditate also of
all thy works and talk of thy doings
it's an active principle it's not a Gaga
State no if you lay in bed and you wake
up at night you can think of what was it
that you read in the Bible and then you
meditate all right so what does this
word meditate Sak mean it's a primitive
root that is by implication converse
with oneself and hence aloud or
transitively utter commune complain
declare meditate Muse pray speak talk
with talk with God through his word yeah
that word to ponder it's not being no
mentally
dead and wherever the spirit leads just
follow no the Bible says test the
spirits and you know if you let it if
you want to now because I know that this
is also being done if you read a passage
of the Bible say for instance a part
where of the New Testament where Jesus
was and his disciples was then you must
imagine yourself in the situation you
must listen to what's going on and what
does Jesus want to tell you and what
does they want to say You must smell
that's how these people that's IGN naian
spirituality that's it but it's under
the Christian G yes of course second
Timothy 31:5 this know also that in the
last days perilous times shall come for
men shall be lovers of their own
selves Covetous boaster proud
Blasphemous disobedient to parents we
know the verse Martin That's
but what's going to happen it's amazing
is again that first one own selves isn't
that one of the main things that they
the all time tell you that's what they
tell you that without natural affection
truth Breakers false accusers
incontinent Fierce despisers of those
that are good traitors he heavy High
minded lovers of pleasure more than
lovers of God and then this having a
form of godliness but denying the power
thereof in other words looking inside
rather than in the word yeah from such
turn away says the
Bible so we read in the 1888 writings by
beholding Christ you become
changed until you will hate your former
Pride your former vanity and self-esteem
your self-righteousness and
unbelief you will cast these sins aside
as a worthless burden and walk humbly
meekly trustfully before God you will
practice love patience gentleness
goodness mercy and every Grace that
dwells in the child of God and will at
last find a place amongst the Sanctified
and holy this is the opposite completely
completely the opposite of what happens
I love what she states here that until
you will hate the former yes you must
hate what you were for do that is if I
must think that I must go back and do
those type of visualizations again I
hate it I don't want to because you're
taken away from yourself and if you did
it then ask God to forgive you and to
get over it and to never ever do it
again
exactly it is through this Avenue of
self-esteem and self-sufficiency that
Satan will seek to ens snare the people
of God Martin has it
happened the you can see the whole world
the whole whole world has happened we've
got this warning it's not only there but
in in the
Bible this is a very very serious
issue so let's take to the next level
which is then Willow Creek bill hbls now
who was he a student of Schuler again
you have a coach who has a coach who
runs to the pope to get his blessings
that's it so you get huh you got the
whole system going you got the whole
system so let's spawn the children
understanding the new terminology so
what is their terminology if you go to
their web page this is their web page
we're not making this stuff up so now if
you read these words you now and ever
you hear them or read them again Y and
get a get a rash yeah break out in
uticaria visualization formation me Ming
I get nauseous when I hear that
spiritual Direction consensus ecumenism
seismic shift we are going to talk about
seismic shifts but in a totally
different context to this nonsense yeah
interp spiritual Community the changing
face of worship stemming the tide
stemming the tide of what so what is
taught meditation promoter writes
positively about man Astic communities
we're back to cells that's what he
said emerging
church so rediscovering spiritual
formation do I really want to discover
what ignasius was doing in his
fitful yeah pathetic states that he was
in and then of course the spiritual
formation and the practices and all of
this has become mainstream
and then they quote books like How big
is your God by Jesuit priest Paul
corinho M these Jesuits are in all the
Woodworks they're like like Bor beetles
yeah eating up the Timbers until the
house falls together that's a very good
analogy because if you look at it you
don't see them you don't see them when
the whole roof comes in and you're gone
okay Martin here's one of my favorites
now not in a positive sense but in a
sense of absolute aversion to what the
man has to say or stand for he's a
Franciscan uh
father let's call him that a priest in
the Roman Catholic
system and he likes Bongo dancers and he
talks about father mother God etc
etc so raw changed some of the prayers
of the Liturgy of the Eucharist opening
the preface he prayed father and mother
God where does he get this nonsense from
you know it's the same as Mormonism they
also believe in mother God and uh before
the consecration of the host he said
before he was given up the death a death
he said yes to and before the
consecration of the wine raw prayed when
supper was ended he gave you thanks and
praise gave the cup to his beloved and
following the consecration Ro said the
Christ blood will be poured out for you
and for all so you will know your sins
are forgiven in praying for The Departed
refer to them as especially your own
beloved who are already with the Lord
that's
spiritism that is immortality of the
Soul so this is Dragon religion mixed
with Beast religion served up as wine to
false prophet religion Y and that's the
whole conglomerate that's the whole
conglomerate of Babylon so Babylon
Fallen has fallen she's become a house
of demons a house of every unclean and
detestable bird I hope this becomes
clear and I hope that we can just make
it or let's just make it clear again
this is Fallen protestantism churches
joining in and we've seen that
absolutely and then he prefaced the Our
Father by saying and now knowing we are
more one than we are many though we come
from different places and races we all
share the same father mother God excuse
me I don't share your father mother God
so I don't want to be in your
party we call Upon Our God together in
the words that Jesus gave us Our Father
Who Art in Heaven no you've just
redefined that deity you've made it a
Ying yet androgenic deity and the only
one that takes those parameters upon
himself is baffet Lucifer a demon Satan
so has Rome changed no they become worse
okay so let's just look at some of his
teachings Martin do you think he
believes that we are gods that we are
Divine well from what he's just stated
I'm sure he does do you think he loves
the the teachings of the serpent in the
Garden of Eden rather than the teachings
of the word of God let's listen we will
now see how Interfaith ISM promotes
virtually the same world view as
witchcraft who are we and most people
don't know you came forth from God your
deepest DNA is divine what you're doing
in contemplation is moving to a level
beneath your thoughts at the level of
pure being the level of of really what
we call Pure Consciousness the mystical
contemplative nonu mind and I use those
three words interchangeably they have
the same thing it's not just two there's
a communion ausing where you become
aware of the very presence of God in you
and as you so it's all a matter of of
Awakening it's all a matter of awareness
and if you're
accessing the now God being
Consciousness what is use whatever word
you're comfortable with it doesn't
really matter it doesn't really matter
it doesn't really matter Richard Roar is
consistent with the book The Common
heart a 20-year review of annual
interface Summits with Buddhist Hindu
Sufi Muslim Jewish Christian and Native
American Shaman participants where they
agreed that God is too big to fit into
one religion Spiritual Authority is
based on inner experience and a person's
soul is
divine that Holy scriptures are only
respected if they lead to the greater
Authority self- knowledge these Concepts
about God and the nature of man are
identical to Witchcraft a form of
shamanism so it's a serpent teacher
teaching that you are divine
wow it's teaching that you are Immortal
I thought Bible says God Alone is
Immortal this
is the serpent had the same lie in Eden
and he hasn't changed his spot either
spots either no he cannot change just
like his protes cannot change so let's
get these quotes from the horse's mouth
let's take the Purpose Driven Life oh
such a wonderful book people claim God
won't ask about your religious
background or doctrinal views the Bible
says take heed of the doctrine yes and
for in vain they teach the Commandments
of
men the only thing that will matter is
did you accept what Jesus did for you
and did you learn to love and trust him
that sounds very nice so you don't have
to obey him no and through exercises you
can get the totally wrong Jesus and you
trust him yes so the last thing many
Believers need today is to go to another
Bible study M this is so disgusting I
just want to get a
fit that a person like this can be
called the father of protestantism this
is a father of Another Kind yeah I think
Jesus addressed them yeah when he spoke
to the Pharisees he said you are of your
father the
devil because if you take people away
from the scriptures you are from the
Devil actually when you do that you're
back in the Middle Ages and doing what
the Catholic Church did they already
know far more than they are putting into
practice not they know nothing yeah I
was a in the worldly terms a highly
educated man yeah a fool according to
the scriptures a fool because the fool
says in his heart there is no God and I
said that so it's the best that I could
master was foolishness wow raren in the
purpose-driven church said that the
spiritual formation movement had a vital
message for the church and has given the
body of Christ a wakeup call yes a
wakeup call to how to die eternally yeah
now Martin let's bring that into a
modern world today we are all computer
geeks right yeah and phone and Phone
Geeks what if we can bring the
spirituality to you in an app yeah then
you can use this technology to further
the devil's work right unknowingly most
of the time you will be partaking in
this yes so your app then becomes your
coach that's it so now you don't have to
go to a little cell group the cell group
has moved into your Lounge into your
bedroom into your into your everyday
situation even when you're sitting for a
meal you're sitting glue to this stupid
little box and let's see what they say
tell us how big hallowe is it's all
glory to God um but he's done yeah had
you told me like a thousand people would
use this thing I would have been mind
blown I we built it initially just for
me um but like 10,000 people a million
people I think we're at 22 million
downloads now like 600 million prayers
prayed there was we were no religious
app uh or meditation app or Wellness app
or workout app had ever cracked the top
10 in the app store before and this past
lent we were number one which was crazy
so it was the first time in history so
why did you build it for you what does
that
mean yeah I was raised religious but
fell away from my faith in high school
and college would have considered myself
agnostic or atheist for most of that
time and when I
graduated I got really into meditation
and uh you know there were some secular
meditation apps that I started using and
I started using them every day and I
loved them um there were like 10 minutes
it was almost like technology without
technology like you press play closed
your eyes plugged in your headphones and
then were just LED in this meditation um
and it was really the first time that
I'd sat in silence uh and the strangest
thing started happening which is every
time I would meditate or sit in silence
my mind kept feeling pulled towards
something spiritual like an image of
Jesus in image of the cross the words
Holy Spirit which I thought was very
strange because I would have considered
myself
agnostic and so I started reaching out
to people who took their faith um more
seriously priests pastors people who I
knew and I thought I had this really
inter question which is hey is there any
way there's some sort of intersection
here between this meditation thing this
sitting in silence thing and this Faith
thing and they all laughed at me and
said yeah we've been doing it for 2,000
years you probably should have heard
about it it's called prayer and I was
like no no no I know prayer prayer is
the like hey thanks for stuff sorry for
Stuff help me with stuff um or the
things that I memorized as a
kid and I had this one priest who said
okay those are great ways to talk to God
it's great ways to share with God what's
on your heart um but have you ever tried
to
listen and I was like no what does that
mean what does it mean to listen to God
uh and I started learning about this
whole world of contemplative and
meditative prayer within the church
things like Lexia deina ignatian
spirituality imagin prayer sitting in
silence chant all this stuff that I'd
honestly never heard of before and I sat
down Lexi deina as a way of meditating
on scripture you pick a word that sticks
out to you and so I Googled how to do
that randomly opened up a Bible and just
10 minutes in my living room uh open up
my Bible to Luke 11 where the disciples
funnily enough ask Jesus to teach him
how to pray and he gives them the Our
Father Our Father who are in heaven
Hallowed be thy name and hallow was the
word that stuck out to me that I
meditated
on and it was just 10 minutes just in
the comfort of my home but I was just
sobbing I it was this beautiful
combination of this deep sense of Peace
like deeper than anything I'd
experienced before
sort of sums it up Martin that shows you
just like you said how all of that came
into an app now isn't it
sad that you have to tell these people
that you've been led by another Spirit
here and remember that they said Leo
deina So Divine reading you're not
reading What God Says you take one word
like hallowed that's what he did read
and that stood out and then he had all
the these visions and things and he was
led by What
Spirit Well he said it's nice to talk to
God you know you ask for things you do
this you do that and the other but how
do you you know get LED well you you
open your Bible so you're using it and
you use it Leo deina Divine reading but
you take this one word that sticks out
you meditate upon it and there you go
down a garden part A a whole something
different from what's standing in the
what is what did they call called Jesus
in the Bible don't they call him the
word mhm and thy word is a lamp unto my
feet and a light unto my path so if I
want to know you I want to
meditate on what God Said mustn't I read
what he said as a whole the word the
whole Bible so ignasius L said no you
don't do that you take a scene yes the
one that he uses in his spiritual
exercises in his writing is the wedding
of
kaan so you visualize this wedding
scene and you visualize him there
turning the water into wine you
visualize Mary and you visualize the
guests and then you become part of the
giest that's okay yeah it's exactly and
then you have to use all your senses
right you have to use your sense of
smell you have to use your sense of
hearing you have to use your sense of
touch you have to use all of those and
then you meditate on something and Mary
says what he what he says
do so the one who actually gives the
instruction is Mary so you cuddle up to
Mary and then you start touching her
clothes and you feel the texture you
smell her
perfume and basically you go on a on a
sort of a love trip and it can go very
wrong this is all that
ignas yes and then you have to
incorporate all your senses into this
thing and you are part of the experience
and then this entity that you are
associated with call it Mary in this
particular case starts talking to you
because you're now part of the scene
yeah now you're getting information now
you're getting information but that
information can be subtle it can appear
to be biblical but it just takes you
around another way then he has another
visualization which is about
hell and he says you have to experience
it so you actually have to visualize the
pain you have to literally feel the pain
of hell and then you have to use your
sense of smell and you have to visualize
smelling the putrid things the worst
smell that you can imagine one that is
nauseating you have to go into that
state and then you have to visualize not
only the pain and you have to hear the
screams of those that are suffering in
there and you have to hear yourself
screaming in pain Etc I mean it's really
violent
disgusting how these visualizations work
but if you take certain aspects of it
and christianize it and put them into
the church like we've seen and then put
them into an app exactly then everybody
goes down this wine of Babylon Road and
they all got their own
little hearing the Own Story yes and
then you get the great actors of the
world to become involved and you use a
series like the chosen for example and
you see that they also use visualization
and use the app etc etc etc well let's
have a look at it
excellent so it's very interesting to me
that the guy that plays Jesus is a Roman
Catholic and very vocal about his Roman
Catholicism he has an app called howo
that he's constantly promoting for
people to join I'm your guide on hallow
a prayer and meditation app to help you
find peace take a deep breath in the
name of the father and of the son of the
holy spirit amen this is a picture of
Jesus being stamped into the Public's
mind and him just naturally being
Catholic is going to make people they're
going to be more sympathetic to that St
Padre said the greatest weapon against
the devil we have is the
rosary try it all right Martin so this
is
introducing Catholic
contemplation now the rosary is
repetitive prayer the Bible clearly says
that you must stay away from repetitive
prayer do not be like the pagans who
repeat over and
over the rosary of course is Mary
centered because you say 10 H Marys one
Our Father 10 H Marys one Our Father 10
Al mares one our father that's how you
go through the beads now the Muslims
also sit with those beads and have
repetitive prayer so it is part of pagan
culture to have repetitive prayer and
then of course finally you have the
Creed etc etc okay just explain so the
beads that thing you you saw the you run
through your fingers right it's that to
keep count to keep count so that you
don't you know you're just saying this
now so you're you're basically altering
your State of Consciousness so you say
10 L mares so the H Mary is Hell Mary
full of grace the Lord be with you
Hallowed Be etc etc etc I mean I could
repeat
it come from that
background but it's Mary centered Mary
Mery cented Mery cented 10 of them one
Our Father leaving out of course the
last verse for thine is the kingdom the
power and the glory forever and ever
because that Kingdom and the power and
the glory belongs to the pope so let's
take that out of that out of that
verse so as opposed to this kind of
repetitive prayer you have the biblical
way of praying so let's just compare the
two prayer is the opening of the heart
to God as to a friend this comes from
the beautiful book steps to Christ not
that it is necessary in order to make
known to God what we are but in order to
enable us to receive him prayer does not
bring God down to us but brings us up to
him centering takes you down yeah prayer
takes you up here's another quote from
the signs of the times there are two
kinds of Prayer the prayer of form and
the prayer of faith the repetition of
set customary phrases when the heart
feels no need of God is formal prayer
when you pray says Christ use not vain
repetitions as the Heathen do for they
think they shall be heard for their much
speaking but the prayer that comes from
an Earnest heart when the simple wants
of the Soul are expressed just as we
would ask an Earthly friend for a favor
expecting that it would be granted this
is the prayer of Faith now interesting
Martin these people will have you repeat
phrases like Jesus or holy or hello or
whatever hundreds of times until you are
totally
hypnotized this is demonic that's I mean
can you speak to somebody like that well
I always said so you know if I had to
sit
down and uh in a Lotus position and say
something nice to my wife let's say I
love you and I were to say it 500 times
I love you I love you I love you I love
you I love you it's like a broken record
that got stuck I love you I love you I
love you eventually she would have to
take a frying pan to put me out of my
misery
gong like a Buddhist Kong how's it even
logical it's not logical it's
pathetic now here's another one of Rick
Warren's plans which was called the
peace plan
now it's a massive effort to mobilize 1
billion Christians around the world into
a church to church Outreach effort so
it's an effort to be led by small group
teams to attack the global Giants of our
day spiritual emptiness corrupt
leadership poverty disease uh social
issues again right so these Global
Giants are attacked in a holistic manner
Etc
first in the church's local community
which they call Jerusalem nearby
communities which they call Judea
Regional area Crossing cultural barries
which they call Samaria and globally to
the entire world and this is why God
made me Rick Warren said everything else
I've done was simply preparation for the
peace
plan now the peace plan and the United
Nations goals are exactly the same
thing so what does the peace stand for
it stands for plant churches equip
leaders assist the poor care for the
sick and educate the Next Generation
with what yeah with spiritual formation
driil that's it tyad dadin he was the
Jesuit philosopher of the United Nations
he's a
Jesuit and the Catholic church had to
sometimes distance itself from what he
said because it was so you know way over
the top that the bulk of the Christian
world would say whoa but he's dead now
and they Embrace everything that he said
they never retract anything like you
said they just go away from like we read
the pope also said um that at first with
a charismatic movement it was oh no I
don't want to and then eventually
embraced he said let's do it yeah so he
like Richard roar or any one of those
who follow this the instructions of the
demon and Serpent of the Garden of Eden
uh realized the point where you know you
realize that you are God W and he's one
of the most quoted writers by Leading
occultists and new
ages and he uses words like value
Genesis Collective cocreation combined
effort Omega point
cosmogenesis where the cosmos comes
together new Genesis where the Minds
come together this is the fusion of
consensus theology it sounds similar to
the um Alpha course Alpha course yeah
cell group where you have your little
coach telling you that we have to have
Fusion on rosac Cru and 12 around one
nonsense right just look at how clever
the devil is because Jesus also said
that we can be one as he and his father
are one so they twist this totally
around and so that it is against what
the Bible says it's interesting that
those that were ready to receive the
holy spirit in the time of Jesus we're
120 yeah so that kind of confuses that
12 around one issue exactly okay maybe
they think 120 is actually 12 plus not
so it's 12 that's how they would
probably talk about it so they want a
new spirituality and it's based on
hegelian dialect IC in a
multiculturalism every faction retains
its identity yet merges into one Cosmic
Fusion the Muslim the Jew the Christian
etc etc they all become one General
soup this is quoted in Roland H Benton
the travail of religious liberty he says
anyone refusing to be hered must be
amputated for the common
good this was the basis for the
extermination of Heretics Augustine
already argued that a horticulturist
prunes a rotten Branch to save a
tree and a doctor imp amputates a
diseased limb to conserve a life even so
may the earring be
constrained that's what they did in the
Middle Ages soon Martin when they have
brought about this Fusion then the ering
who believe in the word of God and not
in this Dil will have to be amputated
the Fundamentalist yeah in order to save
the world for the common good that's it
just to make clear a fundamentalist is
one who believes everything that stands
correct so in the book brainwashing a
synthesis of the Russian textbook on
psycho Politics the author says man is
already a colonial aggregation of cells
there that word again and to consider
him an individual would be an error
sickness could be considered to to be
disloyalty to the remaining organisms
and part of one organism so basically we
can get rid of it yeah we can see with
ease that the Revolt is death and the
Revolt of any part of the organism
results in death thus we see that there
can be no compromise with Rebellion this
philosophy is so entrenched in Jesuit
thinking that they cannot wait for their
Guillotine to become active again
now another one of my
pet uh adversaries in philosophy is
Matthew
Fox and he writes about the coming of
the cosmic Christ and he has this
effeminate Christ there his androgenic
one and it's about the re sacred
response the what sacred everything
sacred creation Stars galaxies wild
Wales soil water that's pantheism modern
that's it so whatever creature dare deny
that it is an immortal Diamond that's
spiritism and original blessing and
image of the Divine one that's the
doctrine of the serpent that you become
God it is my experience that only the
human species dare to deny its Divinity
dares to deny the cosmic Christ so this
Cosmic androgenic good evil salomi
Elijah mixture is the one that they're
worshiping they're worshiping a demon
and are they waiting for this one to
come not the true one no no no this one
oh yes they're waiting for him they
can't wait for him to appear what a
lovely moment they think they will have
so that can mean that you can hear very
wonderful words about we waiting for the
coming of Christ yes but it's not the
one that you of the one of the Bible yes
so let's see what the Roman Catholic
documents have to say about this issue
so let's have a thought here before we
quote them so modern Christianity has
been molded by Jesuit encounter Theology
and spiritual formation Guided by ignazi
and spiritual Direction that's what
we've been showing until the soul is
fragmented and counter dependent and
subservient to the church or your
spiritual
advisor so let's read what the documents
of Vatican 2 had to say ining their
consciences the faith ful must pay
careful attention to the sacred and
certain teachings of the
church for the Catholic church is by the
will of Christ the teacher of Truth so
how they think you must think yeah you
must Wonder with an O after me she says
remember they said if what you see is
white they say is black you believe is
black correct they also say in their
catechism the education of conscience is
indispensable for human beings who are
subjected to negative influence and
tempted by sin to prefer their own
judgment and to reject the authoritive
teaching yes I reject everything in the
Catholic Catholicism so I don't know
what they're going to do are they're
going to amputate me or what Martin
you're going to be
excommunicated that will be a great
honor I think they've done it
already by the way I resigned from the
Catholic Church officially they wrote me
a letter to accept it yes they said no
they didn't accept it directly like that
they said the content has been noted oh
okay it noted okay so it's been
noted so again what is spiritual
formation the Bible speaks about
transformation not
formation be not conformed to this world
but be transformed about the by the
renewing of your mind that you may prove
what is that good and acceptable and
perfect will of God so that has become
you know like the pattern and the
pattern to me is Jesus Christ that's it
all right so I didn't follow Jesus
Christ uh because I was told to do
so my rebellious nature would never
allow
that I started following Jesus Christ
because I saw the way that he
was and uh you know John was a son of
Thunder mhm mhm and he changed because
he watched the pattern yeah and I would
want to change because I watch the
pattern I like everything I read about
Jesus Christ amen I don't know about you
but exactly the same here he the only re
only ruler that I know that doesn't
claim to be a
coach that's so true well just to think
of I was just thinking now
I don't know if there's anybody when
they get um approached with these truths
of wow the Jesuits have infiltrated in
all of this that they don't at first
kick against it oh you'll be
shocked all right so the Bible speaks
about Christ formed within not having a
form from
without my little children Galatians
4:19 of whom I travail in birth again
until Christ be formed in you
now he never forces or coerces you he
just gives you examples in your life of
the consequences of following another
way yeah and they're not always
nice so let's pick it up further opa's
day and formation and we showed some
political figures who were deeply
involved in Opa day in the Trump's new
cabinet right yeah now the founder of
opa's day God's way is Jose Maria
Esa and he talks
about this spiritual formation what does
it actually do that true Christians must
be disciplined and obedient to a
spiritual director that's what it means
in other words give up your own
individuality your own thinking become
brain dead and follow the instructions
of some boo who calls himself a
spiritual director who is trained by
someone who is trained by someone who is
trained by a Jesuit that's it that's the
way it
works then another one he's he's already
deceased now is Richard
Foster and he talks about Christian
psychologist and he's the founder of an
organization that is called
renovare and he again talks about
meditative contemplative Traditions
Mystics Zen Buddhism Psychotherapy Etc
I was one talking to a pastor a high up
official in our
own
denomination and he said to me that this
particular individual Richard Foster
from reading his books is as inspired as
the writer of the spirit of Prophecy W
well that that sort of stunned me to the
core so I just realized how far it that
infiltrated the thinking even of leading
people in our own Society in our own
church wow and I and I thought what am I
going to say to this man now I know what
so I said to him I absolutely agree with
you the one is inspired from above and
the other one from
below it was not happy with me at allow
all right so what is he talking about he
talks about
contemplative the prayer fold life is is
of course contemplative centering prayer
where you realize your own divinity
Holiness The Virtuous life carismatic
the spirit empowered life social
justice incarnational the sacramental
life where you do certain rituals and
walk in certain ways and go
through whatever Labyrinth or all this
nonsense it's Works based and a word
centered life
Evangelical when he talks about word
centered you take one word and you
contemplate right not the word no of
course not so what does he say he says
as you enter the story not as a passive
Observer this is now imagination and
visualization he's explaining it but as
an active participant as we have said
this is exactly what they do this is
ignatian Jesuit theology it's a load of
nonsense remember that since Jesus lives
in the Eternal now and he's not bound by
time this event in the past is a living
present tense experience for him hence
you can actually encounter the living
Christ in the event by be addressed by
his voice and be touched by his healing
power it can be more than an exercise of
the
imagination it can be a genuine
confrontation Jesus Christ will actually
come to you this is a demon appearing it
is so crazy because this is so many
people get caught up in this really
well-meaning Christians yes and it's
dangerous so let's have a look at uh
some quotes from certain of these people
that follow this line of thinking
there's this one DVD called be still and
here are some quotes one of the great
things silence does it gives us a new
concept of God m
Martin so the word gives you a concept
of God exactly and the word speaks you
cannot get a new one outside of what's
already revealed in the Bible the
wonderful thing about contemplative
prayer is that it can be found
everywhere anywhere anytime for anyone
we become a portable
Sanctuary so that we are living our life
wherever it is aware of the goodness of
God than the presence of God oh Divine
Master teach me this mute language which
says so much it says nothing yeah it's
what is conc it up yes it's like
Buddhism the ultimate state narvana is
the state of
nothingness I've always wondered how the
devil has achieved this amazing feat the
punishment for sin is eternal
Oblivion the state of
nothingness and to create a religion
where the state of nothing this becomes
the ultimate thing to strive for is to
me absolutely astounding I've come to
give you life and to give you life more
abundantly not a state of nothingness no
it's directly the opposite exactly the
opposite of the
Bible and if you can do some sacred
dance and some swirling and some
durlings and whether you're a Muslim and
in the Sufi religion or whether you are
in the Christian religion let's
dance so sacred dance so sacred
nothingness Sac of contemplative prayer
where you are God state of no thinking
at all sacred dance promotes sacred
dance as a prayer as a means of
spiritual growth connecting to the
Divine and the integration of mind body
and spirit it's amazing that you every
that we seeing is to you have to do
something to be more spiritual and to
get more answers from God correct Works
based how about being obedient obedient
and read your Bible read your Bible and
be obedient no this is more exciting so
dances performed before a mass by Pope
Benedict will this take you to God or
will it take you somewhere else and
sometimes these these ladies that dance
like this are so scantily clear clad
that they definitely don't take the mind
up with they take them very much into a
base level Martin all these sacred
dances and things do you think the
Jesuits are involved in this again I am
sure they must be coming from everything
evil comes from them right well here you
have the Jesuit Catholic priest father
saju George from India and he performs a
Hindu D dance called
brahan and he claims it gives momentum
to God's word in tangible form so Martin
once you've watched him then God's word
is absolutely clear to
you you know but when I see these things
I see movies you know you've got I used
to watch um you know fighting movies
with Jean Claude vanam and most of these
martial arts movies then they also have
these dances and moves I mean even in
yoga and it's all part of the
spirituality it's all spirituality you
have to it's amazing if you think of
these things now you can see wherever it
it is infiltrated now Martin Protestant
churches
uhhuh uh they surely should be immune to
this sort of stuff right or do you think
they've Swallowed at hookline and sink
and wandered after the Beast
unfortunately that's what the Bible says
the Bible says that now this is not to
to knock them just to show that they
have fallen they have fallen because
they have taken the wine of Babylon they
have been trans
formed into the image of the Beast
they've had a formation yeah but not a
formation from above below not a
transformation no a
formation so if we go and we ask the
Methodist Center for Spiritual
formation that in itself is already a
Mis
Noma how can you have a Methodist Center
for Spiritual
formation all right Gatherings are a day
or a weekend retreat designed to meet
the interests and needs of those seeking
a deeper walk in the spiritual journey
all sers are invited to attend this was
from 2008
209 we could uh see what they're doing
today but it'll be the same thing just
the same thing we've shown still the
same so they start off with a prayer
Labyrinth Martin have you ever read
anything about a prayer labyrinth in the
Bible no I had to actually go and look
up what it is because I didn't know what
it is you have to go walking in this
Labyrinth of in a maze and this will
Enlighten you spiritually so it's a
Buddhist New Age practice wow so it's
amazing amazing it's
amazing yes it's amazing but if you go
to restaurants or
places I hope that people will wake up
and now see these things in a different
eye because there are places where it's
a tranquil setting and they've got a a
maze or a labyrinth that you can go and
yes you can go this is where it comes
from so what this is a supposedly a
spiritual
experience followed by a time of sharing
worship and
communion and then monastic spirituality
I I I think I want to get a heart attack
how can that be in a Methodist Church
Martin Luther taught people to come out
of the monastic system it was from the
devil I mean forcing people to be
celibate and uh Paul says that this
Antichrist who sits in in the Church of
God assuming to be God will teach people
in other words he's e Ecclesiastes not
to marry it's one of the features of the
Catholic church and one of the features
that Paul condemns as one of the
prevalent things of the Antichrist and
here they bring
monasticism that was gotten rid of by
protestantism back what do you think is
it Wesley that started the methodists
yes what do you think he will be saying
about this well he's a sleep mod but if
he weren't asleep he'd be he'd be
probably performing a dance down
[Laughter]
there so monasticism and spirituality
have always been to two sides of the
same coin excuse me there have been two
sides of opposite
coins in the last several decades many
monastic communities have sprung up as
people have have tired of formal
religion and sought a closer communion
with God Mar the Revival of
monasticism you find it in cell
groups that's a cell and that's how it
infiltrated the the um Protestant
churches what else do they do they take
you on active
imagination purely ignatian
spirituality back are we back to this
backdrop for sure look at all those
hands raised over there in Peter
Square very happy following wandering
after the
Beast so journaling through active
imagination Martin this is just
unbelievable have you ever thought that
you would like to journal about but
always end up starting at the blank
sheet of paper you are someone who loves
to journal and would like to develop a
new technique to broaden your journey ex
practice this dayong work workshop will
introduce participants to ways of
journaling that are using guided imagery
entering into biblical stories dialogue
with people place it's ignatian from the
beginning to the end and this is so
dangerous and it's interesting that they
bring in wellness and health the devil
also has a right arm of the Gospel a
health message the New Age movement has
a health message and you know what many
of the things are in line with what
really should be done like a meatless
diet for example but it actually brings
it into dist
repute by putting it into a setting
where many people that still have a
brain and still use it will say well I
want nothing to do with it exactly they
just want to get rid of it so is it only
the methodists let's look at a
presbyterian we web page spiritual
formation is the activity of the Holy
Spirit which molds Our Lives into the
likeness of Jesus Christ no it into the
likeness of your Mentor yeah who is in
the likeness eventually through his
chain of educ ucation with a
pope so this likeness is one of deep
intimacy with God and genuine compassion
for all creation the spirit works not
only in the lives of individuals but
also in the church shaping it into the
body so you have this collective
experience we cooperate with this work
of the spirit through certain practices
which you have to do something a Works
based religion that make us more open
and responsive to the spirit's touch why
don't you read your Bible it's huh it's
like this journaling the journaling they
have prayer journaling and there's a
seven new ways to pray yes we don't need
new ways to pray Jesus gave us the ways
just pray to the Lord let to a friend I
don't need a ritualistic prayer if you
read a book that is called a new way to
pray use it as a
firelighter all right so they take you
through social justice issues compassion
Justice discernment worship
Hospitality spiritual friendship and
then contemplative silence how can you
add such nonsense into the mix
especially when you're a a Protestant
church all right let's have a look at a
more new age way of doing things and
this is all the same thing if it it's
either Christian or new age and ult it's
all the same right so if you have Sacred
Circle company there you have your
little Labyrinth nonsense and you have
your little candles and you have your
little prayer beads or rosaries or
whatever you have so it's an exciting
Innovative partnership offering the
essential material guidance and
information for nurturing spiritual
wholeness so there again you have the
labyrinths you have the little groups
you have the
meditations the whole thing you find it
throughout the Christian
world so here they have a a new age
church and they say this is the church
for the new age this is how it's going
to be done then you're wondering after
the
Beast you have Stillness silence
Solitude
Simplicity Detachment discernment always
that ver verse right but we defined it
in what context it must be devotion
Delight humility healing Holiness
heavenliness by what by sitting in a
Gaga State yeah
H so all of these things I am saying yes
to this invitation are you so can you
now understand why the Catholic Church
Buddhism Hinduism everything fits into
the same pot
yeah that's why most other churches also
now you can Embrace any religion you can
Embrace any religion because the
experience is the norm and nothing
else so the Pope in a multifaith
Singapore says all religions are a path
to God Jesus says I am the only way
there's one way only just to make sure
that um Rome hasn't changed you see this
is now in September 2024 again okay so
Martin does Buddhism accept Jesus Christ
no only as a teacher yeah but they don't
believe in Divinity other than
pantheistic Divinity new age is a
ascended Master no it's an ascended
Master yes who who looks according to
their paintings like Jesus but is
nowhere near
him if you look at what they look like
these manifestations of demons that call
themselves ascended masters or other
christs so what does what does Pope have
to say all paths lead to God well that's
a denial of Christianity right there in
in a line that may once again stir
reaction in more traditional catholic
quarters he wrapped up his three-day
visit to Singapore and he said all
religions are a path to God they are
like different languages in order to
arrive at God but God is God for all the
pope said who had set aside his prepared
text and spoke largely of the cuff since
God is God for all then we are all
children of God yes we are all children
of God by creation but we have to be
children of God by choice yeah don't
that is very true choose thee this day
whom you will serve and you can follow
ba or you could follow Christ that is
your
choice here's an article from September
25 and it comes from the Jesuit Journal
so just once again we'll see now that
the pope said something and now they
have to quickly clarify a little bit
because it's actually against what the
Catholic church is supposed to say about
it oh and the Protestant church and the
Protestant church so so let's see what
the Jesuits have to say this is the
America the Jesuit
review did Pope Francis say that all
religions are equal here's what the
Catholic Church
teaches as so often happens a snippet
from one prompto remark makes it unto
social
media and many read it in a negative
light as though the pope was saying that
all religions are equally true which
would seem absurd since all religions in
some respect contradict one another at
least they admit that but the Pope's
point was that all religions are ways of
communicating with God not that they are
all the
same I don't know that doesn't clarify
that much it sounds like Jesuit double
talk to me a excellent double
talk so how to indoctrinate the mind of
millions and Jesuit theater is of course
a wonderful way to do that and here
little light studio is talking about
some of the confessions of those
involved in the chosen just to show how
this
spirituality is
actually a spiritualism the exact where
you are talking to the deceased and most
of the episodes on in this whole or many
seasons of the series are extra biblical
yes so it probably has they come from
the imagination exactly it's probably
been done through the exercises to get
extra information correct let's have a
look he actually went and sought out
where Lonnie frisbee was buried and this
was scary what he did before I started
work I went over to Christ Cathedral and
uh I I sat by his grave and I prayed a
rosary with him I sat down and I prayed
with him um there this the space just to
his right is empty so I got to sit down
or Li at one point I even lied down
because I just thought it would be kind
of interesting to try to connect in some
way that's probably more information
than you need or may want to publish but
that said uh I you know I it's the truth
and so so I finished praying with him
and I said Lonnie I want to honor you
with this
film and I really want to um to to to
bring Justice and and you know the
Testament to the gifts of God's grace
and and powers that you you know
displayed while you were on this Earth
and
so if this is a good idea that I do this
film have somebody Give Me A Sign Give
Me A Sign God give me a sign and the
minute the words left my
mouth behind me there was a door open to
the cathedral and this giant cord rang
out for about five seconds and then from
the organ from the organ wow I hadn't
heard it before and that's the very
organ that used to be there when it was
the C it's the same organ that when it
was the Crystal Cathedral mm it was sent
out and refurbished and whatnot but it's
the same one so I heard that and I was
like
okay thanks for that I'm wearing a
mantle and a cross with a little crown
on it uh a knight's
cross uh 5 years ago I was uh knighted
by the order of the
solemn uh Sovereign military order of
the Temple of Jerusalem I lost my mind
there for a second um essentially the
knight's Templar which is what that is
Martin firstly he was speaking to a dead
man and praying with him
well if you're speaking to a dead man
aren't you really praying to him then
yeah and telling him that he wants to
honor him with this thing and uh does
the Bible forbid
that very very clearly it forbids it
right necromancing if I'm not mistaken
it's necromancy it is it had the death
penalty upon it so in other words you uh
you were in a state where you are
actually cont contemplatively speaking
to a demon if you get an answer mhm so
when from the Crystal
Cathedral I don't know which Crystal
Cathedral he's referring to but if it
was Robert Schuler one it would make a
lot of
sense there was this massive organ
blasting forth that was his
confirmation so mtin if you rely on
signs like that you are on very very
dangerous ground because Satan will give
you the sign that is so important
because we must be careful God can use
certain things to show you in a
direction if you want him but it won't
be almost never I don't don't think that
it will be a physical sign like this it
will be something that is um happening
in a people are yes saying something or
you know it will be not in a diff direct
sign like this so I need a sign whether
I should go with this girl although I'm
married so if something would amazing
would happen like a rose fall in front
of me for now well then I know that I
must leave my wife or there must be a a
lightning bolt and then you drive around
to search for a
storm and you get a lightning bolt okay
that's my son here I go thanks for the
confirmation it's a very dangerous thing
but there's a very clear verse which
says no no no Dangerous Ground here
right exactly
Martin this is amazing stuff and as we
see this is a kned
individual and he plays the role of
Jesus he plays the role of Jesus how
many people have been influenced or yeah
as this series this is the way it goes
you know what I watched the first few
ones until I came to the point where
Jesus asks advice of Matthew and prac is
his sermon before Matthew and Matthew
sets him straight and I said you know
what I cannot watch this blasphemy any
longer and I put it off and I have never
watched it ever since and I don't intend
to but now he acknowledged that he's a
ni
Templar isn't that part of the Jesuits
as well of course it's controlled by the
Jesuit order it's the same think tank so
this is a Christian series yes but it's
ruled by the Jesuits yes and just
because
the the one who's in control picks up a
Desire of Ages M and holds that up is it
possible that those who belong to the
Advent denomination would say well then
it must be okay let's go oh everybody
it's very deceptive here's another clip
I'm making a show about Jesus where 95%
of the content isn't from the Bible most
of the content of this show is not
directly from scripture I know that
sounds horrible but but it's true if you
watched episode one of season 1 almost
none of that is from scripture if you
watch episode two of season 2 none of it
is from scripture episode 3 none of it
from scripture episode four most of it
not from scripture I think when they see
this version of Jesus portrayed he has
his own flaws in a human way like he's
very relatable and um and gracious and I
think people need to see that that side
of Jesus cuz we've a lot of us have been
force-fed
um you know a a version of Jesus that
only cares about our behaviors every
episode the story pushes back on that so
everything is non-scriptural
the Mormons were involved in it as well
and he wasn't a being with flaws and if
you see the flaws you can identify with
him I thought he was Flawless Martin he
was the only individual who was without
sin H they bring again Jesus down
towards us instead of taking us towards
him correct isn't sad the Jesuits and
The Counter Reformation is a very very
serious issue and all of these
denominations have fallen have
fallen and they've come to the point
where they are now a house of demons if
you practice these things you're
practicing demonology it's a house of
demons whether we like it or not it
sounds very harsh but that is the
reality
Revelation 7:3 saying hurt not the Earth
neither the sea nor the trees till we
have sealed the Servants of our God in
their foreheads I want to know how to be
sealed because we are living in the
sealing
time bind up the testimony seal the law
amongst my disciples Martin that's the
way to
go the testimony to the law and to the
test testimony if they speak not
according to this word he just said
there was nothing biblical in it to the
law and to the testimony if they speak
not according to this word there is no
light in them and if there is no light
in them then there's only darkness in
them it's from the devil wow that is a
very good analogy that you once again
did I didn't do it no but5 is it 95% is
not in out of that so it's not to the
Lord the testimony not according to the
law and to the testimony so if I want to
be sealed I must live according to the
law and to the testimony the Bible is my
guide just as soon as the people of God
are sealed in their forets in other
words in your cognitive
capacity it is not any seal or Mark that
can be seen but a settling into the
truth Thy word is
truth both intellectually and
spiritually so that you cannot be moved
God said so I don't care how many
formations you have I don't care how
much my coach tells me that I mustn't
use this Doctrine or that Doctrine I'm
going to stick to what the word of God
said I'm very happy about the word
that's used there intellectually yes
because spiritual formation doesn't have
a lot of intellectually it's a lot of
emptiness and brain deadness and aava
like a corpse just as soon as God's
people are sealed and prepared for the
shaking it will come and the shaking
will be on the details of God's
word indeed it has already begun the
judgments of God are now upon the Earth
to give us warning that we may know what
is coming the days are fast approaching
when there will be a great perplexity
and confusion Satan clothed in Angel
robes will deceive if possible the very
elect there will be God's many and
Lord's many every wind of Doctrine will
be blowing except biblical Doctrine I I
think we're seeing this already we're
seeing this
absolutely so let's end with Isaiah
64:8 and Jeremiah yet oh Lord you are
our father we are the clay You Are The
Potter we are the work of your hand who
as Jeremiah puts it oh House of Israel
cannot I do with you as this Potter says
the Lord behold as the clay is in The
Potter's hand so are ye in mine hand oh
House of Israel so M mankind doesn't
like to be molded no and God wants to
mold you but he doesn't want to force
you so he wants you to study his word
not to go and sit in a brainless Lotus
position bumbling through a labyrinth
and thinking that you've now become a
spiritual being on the other side of
that nonsense no he wants you to study
the word of God to incorporate its
teachings and to make a decision do I
want to live in harmony with us or not
it is a choice choice let's pray thank
you heavenly father they have surely
infiltrated the minds of men and led
them down a liberan of garden
paths whereas we have a sure word of
Prophecy unto which we do well to take
heed to the law and to the testimony if
they speak not according to this word it
is because there is no light in them
help them to realize this to separate
from Babylon to come out so that they
receive not of the plagues is my prayer
in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]